good morning John it's a today the day
of YouTube's live in a day project today
in which they're asking the entire world
to document their lives they're asking
everyone to answer three questions the
first one is what is in your pocket well
I've got my pocket is my Droid X brand
new phone very fancy as big as it's like
holding an iPad up to my ear it's
humongous this is my waterproof camera
which I'm going to use later finally the
only other thing I have in my pocket is
my pills I have to take these every day
without further ado John let's go see my
day we did a lot of driving so that's
how we're just gonna start out we're
gonna start out driving to the farmers
market the farmers market is a pretty
big deal in Missoula and we started off
by getting some food because we were
very hungry this guy made Katherine
fried egg sandwich he also made a fried
egg sandwich for about a thousand other
people it was pretty amazing to watch
and then this girl made me some peanut
curry or at least she ladled some peanut
curry on to some rice for me it turned
out to be one of the hottest days of the
year and earlier that day we had seen
one of lemons coping strategies for hot
days oh my god this dog has us totally
whipped so the market was packed and
pretty much all of the best veggies were
there so we loaded up and then we
watched some guys juggle which after
having seen root Berry perform wasn't as
impressive as it used to be and then we
went over to the Clark Fork where
there's a kayak wave and they were
kayakers and this still looks very
impressive to me and then back to the
car to our community garden plot which
we have because our condo does not have
a yard and so we love to garden we must
have a community garden plot I'm at my
garden I just picked a bunch of dill and
my fingers smell like dill some of my
onions are falling over which means it's
time to pull them it's hot it's hot and
summery
we have some flowers here to John you
don't got to go to Germany to see
sunflowers that's a big leap out of the
beautiful beet hmm look at the beautiful
bounty of wonderful food people just
putting in their hard work making food
for themselves this land is actually
owned by the cemetery it's over there
that we get it really cheap on the
provision that if they want it they can
have it at any points to bury more dead
people and more dead people well there's
no dead people in here right now
we drove over to see some friends who
are visiting from Portland and then back
to the car
well at a friend's house taking care of
her chickens she raised his chickens for
a living this isn't like her personal
flock or anything and then of course my
very favorite part splash Montana I grew
up in Florida so by my standard issues
like this adorably quaint and tiny water
park so mostly we just lounged around
Katherine ate a horrible thing that was
delicious but we did go on some slides
and while I was on one slide I entered
the second question which is what am I
afraid of and then later that night we
were walking in Katherine saw this sign
and she made up a song about it here he
goes one large two top sticks and two
pops off for $16 staff the beats hot
line and John I never did answer the
last question which is what do you love
and I just find that to be a very
difficult question to answer because I
would just be talking for a long long
time I could just list all of the things
in this video I love juggling and I love
farmers markets and I love babies and
Friends and Katherine and Doritos and
water parts I love all those things I
love video I love making video and I I
love what it represents so thanks to
everyone who's involved in this from
John who had the idea in the first place
to everyone who watches who makes this
you know possible so thank you and John
I will see you on Wednesday